foreign
founded his first company when he was 18
and then sold that at 21 and followed by
that he launched cow finder where he
bootstrapped that business to 25 million
dollars in sales without bringing in a
cent of outside funding After exiting
cow finder gave started up shift which
is a growth stage accelerator program to
help startup scale sales teams in months
as opposed to years in the past six
months of ship graduates have raised
over 52 million dollars in funding I
first heard about Gabe when Tim Ferriss
retweeted this amazing blog post about
how he bootstrapped Cal Finder right
when I saw it I knew we had to have him
here so today Gabe's going to give the
lowdown on how he's been able to help
teams scale their sales teams so please
give a warm welcome for Gabe
hey good afternoon
so my name is Gabe founder of upshift
Partners we help start up scale sales
and make money
so like many of you I'm a entrepreneur
and I'm here today to share some of the
lessons that I learned going from an
idea in a spare bedroom to multi-million
dollar company without ever having to
raise a penny of outside funding
to say that my journey here was unique I
think would be a kind of an
understatement so I didn't go to an Ivy
League school in fact dropped out of
college
never raised a penny of VC funds
bootstrapped it on my own credit cards
and
I also grew up on a hippie commune in
Northern California
where we didn't have electricity
we didn't have a television
we didn't have internet
and I didn't have a whole lot of
examples of I guess successful
entrepreneurs in fact that the only
entrepreneurs that I knew on the hippie
commune were
farmers
but yet eight years ago in in the heart
of Silicon Valley I started a tech
company without having an email address
or a computer
so if I can do it anyone can
so again the reason that I'm here today
is really to share some of the lessons
that I learned in in the hopes that you
don't make all the same mistakes that I
do or that I did
so these are really three powerful
lessons that I learned uh unfortunately
the hard way the first one was really
the power of doing more with less
because we didn't have a lot of money in
the bank and we had to focus the second
thing is making the system the hero from
the very beginning
and the third is to let Data Drive
decisions so I'll dig into these things
a little bit more throughout my talk
I also wanted to give everyone here an
opportunity to just listen and learn so
I actually wrote an article on exactly
what I'm talking about today including
all the fine details of it and it's
available at upshiftpartners.com
dispatch so you'll be able to access the
entire article so I encourage you to
just you know put pens and computers
down and just sit back and and relax
so doing more with less
hmm
we started our companies just simply
with our credit cards to be able to get
our company launched so we didn't have a
whole lot of cash in the bank
and fortunately we were able to get it
off the ground and we were able to get
it up to about three million dollars in
annual sales
and then we just hit this plateau
where it was like no matter how much
Brute Force we were using the the top
line numbers just weren't growing
and I can remember this one day sitting
down and and you know we were pretty
ambitious we wanted to double the
revenue of the company every single year
and I can remember sitting down actually
looking at the numbers and thinking oh
like I'm gonna have to hire three
times as many sales people in the next
like four months to get this growth
and although I was willing to do that
like I'm I'm a hustler at heart I knew
that God I just don't want that to be
the first option I knew that in my gut
like there had to be a better way than
just simply Brute Force
and so the next morning I came into the
office and I printed off our entire
customer list at this point we actually
had computers so it was it was amazing
so printed off the customer list and sat
down with it and actually started
looking through all the customers and
and how much they were spending on uh
with our platform
and I something caught my eye I found
that there was these two customers that
were spending about 10 times the amount
of Revenue in the same period of time as
our average customer
and it got my attention
kind of the light bulb started to go off
and I started to ask around and ask the
different team members
you know why are these people spending
so much more than everyone else
and honestly nobody had a really good
answer for me
so I went on Elance and I hired an
internet researcher
to basically take our top 10 customers
and our bottom 10 customers and look at
like all the other attributes that we
didn't currently have so you know we had
name and address and that kind of basic
information but what we didn't have was
things like how many counties did these
business cover how long at their website
uh been up or when did it when was it
most recently updated what were they
doing as far as online advertising what
were they doing on social
and we got the results back a few days
later and I can say that 98 of it didn't
tell us anything
but it was that two percent that was
actually really valuable we saw these
similarities between the customers that
were these kind of 10x customers and
also similarities in the like the bottom
uh 10 customers
and and I started to look at it and say
wow like in order to double the company
I only need to get 20 of these customers
as opposed to 200 other customers
and and I always describe myself as
being productively lazy
so I look for the fastest way that also
requires the least amount of effort in
order to kind of achieve the goals
so I started looking at it and said okay
I went back onto Elance hired another
researcher and said I want you to find a
hundred people that match this exact
same criteria that are that these two
10x companies match
a few days later we get this list back
we did is we said okay we're going to go
after this really small list of super
high value customers the first thing we
need to do is get their attention they
don't even know about us
so what we did was we designed this
really clever campaign where basically
and this is I think what where my my
hustle side came in is basically said
we're going to hit these companies from
every single side for 12 weeks straight
and we're going to get all of their
attention
so what we did is we sent out a little
direct mail piece with kind of a clever
gift and a clever handwritten note that
got their attention we sent that out
every single week and then we would call
behind the direct mail campaign
so we sent out the first one
waited for the phones to ring nothing
happened
sent out the second one waited for the
phones to ring nothing happened
four weeks go by and my co-founder and
uh and our sales people are like yeah
that was just another one of Gabe's
crazy ideas that didn't really work
and it's a Wednesday afternoon and and
my cell phone rings and I pick it up
and guy says yeah is this game yes he
says this is Steve you've got my
attention what can you do for me
I was so caught off guard that I had to
tell me I was in the middle of a meeting
and call him back and I looked up his
information this is the CEO of a four
billion dollar company that has just
called me on my cell phone
so
end up setting a meeting with Steve
week five get another phone call
two weeks later get two more phone calls
play it out four months later we'd
signed over two million dollars in new
business and when we tallied up what we
spent in marketing it was less than two
thousand dollars
the most amazing marketing return you
could ever imagine
and what I learned in doing that was was
a couple
big things first off and this is more
for people that that don't yet have
customers is focus on customers that
kind of meet three criteria they have
the most pervasive
urgent and costly need
the second thing is if you're already
running and you already have a customer
base look at the top 10 and the bottom
ten and actually spend the time dig into
all the attributes and try to understand
what makes those people the top ten or
the bottom tent don't just kind of use
the spray and pray approach
and then in the words of Notorious Big
Mo Money Mo Problems
the reality is you know if we had 10
million dollars in the bank I wouldn't
have been forced to be that creative so
money buys a lot of things it doesn't
necessarily buy creativity and it
doesn't certainly doesn't buy Hustle
so lesson two uh is really about making
the system the hero when I was in
college my I would say my first job
after making deli sandwiches where I
actually got fired from that's when I
decided that um I should be a CEO
um my my kind of first Real World
experience I got an internship where I
got to start and run my own house
painting company I know you're all
thinking wow what a sexy job but over
the course of a summer what I did was
actually go literally go around and
knock on doors and get leads of people
who want to get painting work done and
then do estimates and and
um you know and end up booking work and
running a house painting company what I
learned in doing that was two really
core things one was the power of hustle
like knocking on ten thousand doors
before I ever turned 21 getting chased
by dogs and whatnot and the second thing
was really the power of a good system
and so I took that into the next company
that we started so we started my last
company Cal finder
um literally without email addresses or
computers but we knew the power of a
system so we wanted to test the concept
and what we did was we took four yellow
notepads four pens and we wrote down a
really simple script
um that we were going to test on
homeowners to see if they would want to
get connected with Home Service
professionals and we took those basic
scripts out and we took our yellow
notepads we went and knocked on doors
because that's what we knew how to do we
didn't know how to build software or
anything
and the first day we get back and and
we'd collected about 10 names and phone
numbers people that wanted work done
it's pretty surprising
the next day we followed a similar
process so what we did was we looked in
the Yellow Pages and tried to find
contractors that had the biggest ads
because we knew they were spending money
and we wrote down a script and a kind of
a pitch that we would use then we went
to their offices and we pitched them on
the concept and said Hey listen would
you be interested in getting homeowners
that want to get work done on their
houses
they said yes
we said well how much would you pay
classic Hustler move
and they said 80 bucks
so we asked them if they had a photocopy
machine
and we took these yellow notepads and we
went into their office and we made a
copy
and we got them to write us a check for
800 bucks to buy the 10 names
and that was like our seed capital
and then we went to the next
contractor's office and we followed the
same script and asked them how much
they'd be willing to pay they said 100
bucks so we did the same thing made
another thousand bucks
third contractor we asked the same
questions says 120 bucks make 1200 more
bucks so maybe three thousand bucks in
our first day we're like fist pumping
and thinking we're going to be
billionaires by the end of the month
um but what we what we were able to do
is we took those same scripts and the
next week we went to college campus and
we said ask college kids if they wanted
to make 30 bucks an hour
took them out the next week got 40 leads
using that same script followed the same
process with contractors and we just
rinsed and repeated we made the system
better every single week and that's what
enabled us to go from me being the first
salesperson to 10 sales people to 25 to
50 without ever raising any outside
funding
so my advice is make the system the hero
from the very beginning you know when
you look at companies like Uber or Lyft
they're expanding into all these new
markets and they have a playbook for
everything
and so it's never too early to start
building your playbook
the second thing is if you're doing
something more than twice it needs to be
documented there needs to be a checklist
otherwise you're always going to do that
task or somebody else is going to do a
shitty job of it
the third thing is set a schedule to
iterate especially if you're early in
the game there's probably some really
simple things that you're doing every
week whether it be having conversations
with customers or trying to get your
first sales like start then build a
Playbook and then iterate on it every
single week
so lesson three and I would say this was
one of the most painful lessons that I
learned and and I've had to learn it a
couple of times but but I want to share
a story with you that was a pivotal
moment in my last company
so we've taken the company and we were
at the time we were going after kind of
a small business segment so it was a
very much like a high volume approach
and we had built a sales organization to
50 sales people which is a incredibly
challenging thing to do and it's also
kind of like hurting cats imagine 50
sales people in one room it's it's kind
of a nightmare
so we built a company to 50 sales people
we had 4X the number of deals that we
were doing even a short period before
um and we had had about six months in
doing that and and started to look at
the numbers
and it was like I remember this like
rock dropping into my belly and and
realizing that we had made like a
massive mistake
and only six of those sales people were
actually performing when we looked at
all the numbers
um what had happened is that we hired
all these people very excited signing
lots of deals but all the customers were
churning out and we had really like bad
customer satisfaction ratings
so we looked at these six and these six
sales people were just they were killing
it they were doing incredibly well
and we looked at the bank account and
again we didn't have a whole lot of
buffer and if we looked at the numbers
and we said if we continue on this path
we'll be bankrupt in 45 to 60 days
and I like it still hurts when I think
about it but we had to make a massive
course correction this is one of the
most difficult things I've ever done in
business
we let go of 42 people the next week
these are people that had given like
their lives to helping grow the company
and it was just heartbreaking
and what we did is we went back to the
drawing board and we looked at all the
data from all the six from the six
people that were being really successful
and what we found is that they were
going after a different kind of customer
type and they had a a like a certain
kind of timing that they were using to
get in touch with them
and so what we did was again going back
to lesson two we started to build a
recipe around what these six people were
doing
play that forward and we had actually
doubled the revenue of the company
without hiring another sales person over
the next 12 months
so one of the most difficult decisions
that I ever made but if I let my ego get
in the way of of actually making an
objective decision based on data I
wouldn't be up here on this stage today
talking to you about our success
so what did I learn from this
I learned to always let Data Drive
decisions this is something that's just
absolutely critical for startups there's
so many moving parts and so many
challenges that you have to let Data
Drive decisions and if the highest paid
person in the room is is purely relying
on gut you're going to get yourself into
trouble pretty quickly and you might end
up down a road that's really hard to
correct from
the second thing is doing the best to
remove ego from decision making
so our question always is you know what
does the data say not what do you think
what's your opinion on it what does the
data say
and then the third thing is to manage by
the numbers and this is oftentimes a
transition for startups from the early
craziness where you're just like
throwing spaghetti against the wall
seeing what sticks and transitioning out
of that and actually building a
sustainable company and having that kind
of transparency to run the company by
the numbers
so
you know this this last lesson I don't
need to harp on it but it was one that
was kind of a culmination for me and
it's an area in in going through that
process and having to actually let go of
all those people and also to rebuild the
company what I learned was obviously
that the power of focus and doing more
with less
I also learned to to let the system be
the hero and build the system around
what's working
and then also to let Data Drive
decisions
so
now I I um I wanted to take a little bit
of time to answer some questions either
on my own path of you know scaling my
last company or you know what we've
learned in helping seven startups to
scale sales over the last seven months
so happy to answer questions yeah
questions
uh hey Gabe thanks for taking the time
to do this today
um I helped Sam a little bit with hustle
combat um during the day I'm a sales
development rep at zenefits so I thought
what you said was really interesting can
you talk more about those six people
that were sort of the outliers with
um in your organization what they did
differently than the other 42 that you
cut off
yeah so the things that we started to
notice was
they they were going after actually a
different customer segment and they were
taking more of a I would call like a
sniper approach as opposed to like the
AK-47 approach
so these people if if our average
salesperson they were calling on smbs
right so it was a big volume game and
the height of things we were doing about
20 000 outbound calls a day
and these sales people were doing like
five calls a day each
but yet the people that they were
talking to were highly qualified and
also had the potential to spend a lot
more on the platform and they also set
great expectations so we didn't have
churn
uh with those people so that's those are
the kind of the attributes that we found
with those sales people so were they
doing mostly email Outreach or like how
are they getting they were doing email
and then following up with a phone call
um and so that was like the approach
that seemed to be working for them
cool thank you cool
any other questions please come down
oh okay
nope okay all right thanks very much
Gabe sure